everything's personal and ant-man and
the wasp the small-scale superhero movie
is a light and summaries story with no
real villains just characters trying to
get things done and get home sometimes
at odds with each other
but while the unmanned sequel stakes may
be small the characters themselves have
long histories are stretched back
decades and we're not just talking about
the two of their names and the title
there's more going on with some of these
supporting characters and you may have
noticed and they may affect the future
of the entire MCU when it comes to
ant-man and the wasp these are the
characters that deserve your extra
attention
Cassie Lang Scott Lang's daughter Cassie
is ant-man and the wasp Secret MVP in
one of the movie's most adorable moments
the ten-year-old makes it clear to her
dad that she wants to be a superhero
sidekick it's a suggestion that Scott
brushes off at least for now
in the comics Cassie does get in on the
superhero game working both on her own
and with the Young Avengers under the
names of stature and stinger like her
dad she has size changing abilities
gaining the power to do so without the
help of Eddie technology through a
lifetime exposure to Pym particles so
why does Cassie's comic-book history
matter to the MCU
well Marvel Studios President Kevin
Feige has openly discussed how the
company is planting seeds for the
younger vengers potential arrival in the
movies saying that's why we wanted
Cassie inspired by her father you may
see that inspiration pay off sooner than
you think as Marvel has reportedly cast
an older actress to play Cassie and a
fourth Avengers movie is this aspiring
heroine about to get a time in the
spotlight it certainly seems that way
Elias star a liar star only appears and
flashed back in the ant-man sequel
being the bold man who gets blown up in
a quantum experiment as part of ghosts
origins story
Molly may be a sympathetic figure in the
movie his comic-book namesake is
anything but introduced in a 1962 issue
of tales to astonish Elias has a
Brainiac villain appropriately named as
egghead a super genius who becomes
obsessed with defeating ant-man and the
Avengers you don't really get any of
that in the movie though instead elias's
animosity toward Pym is transferred to
his daughter Ava aka ghost who has a
reflexive - stays for Pym due to what
she sees as his part in her parents
death that fatherly aspect to egghead is
entirely an invention of the MCU in
comics Ava doesn't exist speaking of
which
ghost ghost is one of the more
mysterious characters in the andaman and
the wasp with no time for chitchat
she's got an understandable focus on
staying alive and finding a cure for her
in comfortable phasing condition before
it tears our parts motivated by survival
Ava's the most sympathetic bill in the
MCU has seen yet by the time the credits
roll and ghost is cured Scott's casually
referring to Ava as the team's new ghost
friend making a story feel less like a
villains tale a more like a backdoor
pilot for a whole new hero in MCU
territory they call that move the Bucky
Barnes in the comics ghost has not named
Ava nor is she a che the comic book goes
to man whose real name we never learned
was introduced as a villain in a 1987
issue of Iron Man eventually the
character joins the Thunderbolts a team
of bad guys gone good since ghost
survives up man in the wasp fans are
chattering about the possibility of the
antihero eventually joining a movie
version of the Thunderbolts well we
don't know for sure that's happening
some of the pieces are in place in the
comics the team was originally led by
Baron Zemo a character who appeared in
and survived Captain America Civil War
Jimmy woo but he believed that FBI
Special Agent James Jimmy was the
ant-man and the wasp character with the
longest comic-book history with the
character first introduced in 1956 it
might also explain why he's such an
unabashed square ruas such an
old-fashioned character that he predates
Marvel Comics as a company first
appearing in an Atlas comic series about
a Chinese super villain named the yellow
claw a name which aged very poorly
hey is complicated it's complicated when
atlas turned into Marvel we eventually
ended up be packaged as a SHIELD agent
but Marvel never forgets his Atlas
comics roots eventually making in the
center of a new team called the agents
of atlas in 2006 a squad composed of
retro heroes from the 40s and 50s whose
quaint style in ant-man and the wasp
seems like a reference to his origins in
another era being a stickler for the
rules makes him a natural he'll in a
world where Scott Lang technically a
criminal can be among the ranks of the
world's mightiest heroes we are both
captain Daniel Gubler the whale boat
captain played by comedian Tim Heidecker
is not a comic book character
rather a manifestation of a real-life
insight joke it all goes back to the
satirical movie review series on cinema
at the cinema starring Heidegger and
comedian Greg Turk in turn a show on
which ant-man director Peyton Reed once
appeared ever since turkleton cameoed in
the first unmanned a scott's
baskin-robbins manager the two co-hosts
have been locked in a rivalry over which
of them can appear in more Marvel movies
a competition Tim tide in 2015 by
appearing in Fox's Fantastic Four
reboots I completely understand why you
would want to be involved with it why
you would pay the fifteen thousand
dollars to get that camera movie we're
not so now now that Tim's lunged into
the league with this appearance in a man
and the wasp the tables have turned on
Turkey turn the appearance makes her one
of the movie's most amusing gags why did
you know about the long-running insight
joke bill Foster
Laurence Fishburne's bill foster serves
as an ant-man on the wasp antagonist for
about five minutes with any felony on
his part coming down to a difference in
perspectives
the professor is introduced as a former
partner of Pimm's who worked alongside
him on a project called Goliath but
what's never made too clear as like
Goliath is a former superhero alter ego
of Hanks and that for a while Foster was
Goliath after parting ways with Pym
FASTA gained the power to grow to great
heights himself through his tinkering
with Pym particles he then started a
blaxploitation era crime-fighting career
as a hero black Goliath in a 1975 issue
of Power Man later after using the name
Giant Man for a while faster would just
take the name Goliath while faster never
goes gigantic in the ant-man sequel he
definitely has the ability to which may
come in handy in the future this is
assuming bill survived the movies credit
scene with one man and two wasps snap
out of existence the remaining heroes
probably need all the help they can get
thanks for watching
take the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to